damit der bundestag nicht noch weiter
wächst unionsfraktionschef brinkhaus
legt einen vorschlag für eine
wahlrechtsreform vor polen am scheideweg
der national konservative präsident du
da möchte wiedergewählt werden
10 herausforderer wollen den wechsel
entscheidung in der zweiten liga
bielefeld und stuttgart steigen aus in
die relegation schafft es heidenheim und
nicht der hsv
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen bei unseren
nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag und der
sport ist auch dabei mit norbert lehmann
ein stück unserer familie und wir
beginnen mit einem problem dass berlin
schon länger beschäftigt der bundestag
platzt aus allen nähten
noch nie gab es so viele abgeordnete und
damit es bei der nächsten wahl nicht
noch mehr werden muss schleunigst etwas
passieren
jetzt hat unions-fraktionschef brinkhaus
einen neuen versuch gestartet das
wahlrecht so zu reformieren dass es
zumindest eine deckelung gibt während
benzin erklärt worum es dabei geht
noch nie war der bundestag größer noch
nie war er teurer und eine
wahlrechtsreform gelegt seit jahren
nicht wegen überhang- und
ausgleichsmandaten sitzen statt 598
aktuell 709 abgeordnete im bundestag aus
der cdu jetzt der vorschlag 750 soll die
obergrenze sein
das ist ein notfall mechanismus weil der
königsweg ist die reduzierung der
wahlkreise
das müsste man aber da noch bis 20.12
sich hinkriegen was sehr ambitioniert
ist widerstand kommt aus den eigenen
reihen
vor allem der fraktions partner csu
stemmt sich gegen den vorschlag weil
dann theoretisch bei den direktmandaten
gekürzt werden müsste wir als csu im
bundestag sind für eine reduzierung der
größe des bundestages aber einen
vorschlag der dazu führen würde dass
gewählte wahlkreisbewerber nicht in den
deutschen bundestag einziehen können
halten wir für verfassungswidrig also
die csu blockiert nach wie vor jede
vernünftige lösung jeden vorschlag den
es gibt der nicht zu ihrem eigenen
nutzen ist grüne fdp und linke wollen
ihren vorschlag vor allem weniger
wahlkreise in der kommenden woche zur
abstimmung stellen
wir müssen das problem ganz schnell
lösen denn
in diesem sommer werden möglicherweise
sonst schon kandidaten aufgestellt ein
jahr vor der bundestagswahl also in
diesem september müssen die spielregeln
klar fest stehen und deshalb ist die
sache hoch dringlich ab morgen läuft in
berlin die letzte sitzungswoche vor der
sommerpause die zeit drängt in polen
wird heute ein neues staatsoberhaupt
gewählt für die rechtskonservative
regierung geht es um viel
sie unterstützt den amtierenden
präsidenten duda der ist zwar favorit
könnte aber laut umfragen die absolute
mehrheit verpassen
aussichtsreichster position kandidat ist
der liberale und europafreundliche
warschauer bürgermeister laskowski um 21
uhr schließen die wahllokale
warum hat denn diese wahl für die polen
so eine große bedeutung natalie steger
nun es geht vor allem darum gibt es ein
weiterso oder fällt das machtmonopol der
pis der präsident mit seiner
unterschrift setzt er gesetze in kraft
und genau das hat er in den letzten
jahren getan er hat geliefert für die
pis auch bei so umstrittenen
gesetzesvorhaben wie der justizreform
der warschauer bürgermeister der in
umfragen jedenfalls in einer stichwahl
in zwei wochen gute chancen gegen du da
hätte der hat bereits angekündigt dass
er ein gegengewicht darstellen will also
nicht mehr reflexartig unterschreiben
sondern gesetze gegebenenfalls auch
verhindern und das würde für die pis
bedeuten dass der umbau des landes für
sie empfindlich schwere würde
vielen dank natalie nach warschau in
zwei stunden wissen wir vielleicht schon
mehr wenn erste hochrechnungen zur
präsidentenwahl in polen und viele
weitere informationen haben wir dann
online auf heute de und in unserer zdf
heute corona tests für jeden der will
hat bayern angekündigt als erstes
bundesland gesundheitsministerin humme
sagte dies werde kostenfrei und
unabhängig von symptomen möglich sein
außerdem würden tests in pflegeheimen
und krankenhäusern massiv ausgeweitet
ebenso in der fleischindustrie im kreis
gütersloh steigt die zahl der gemeldeten
corona infektionen jetzt auch außerhalb
des fleisch betriebs von tönnies
in den letzten 7 tagen haben sich 75
personen infiziert meldet der kreis die
tests wie hier an der drive in station
wurden massiv ausgeweitet es kommen auch
menschen ohne krankheitssymptome
viele hoffen mit einem negativen test in
den urlaub fahren zu können
bis dienstag gelten in den kreisen
gütersloh und warendorf vorerst noch
verschärfte regeln insbesondere wegen
dieser lokalen corona ausbrüche hat sich
die zahl der neuinfektionen in
deutschland insgesamt erhöht im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
steckten sich täglich 540 menschen neu
mit dem virus an
gestern waren es 530 weltweit gibt es
inzwischen mehr als zehn millionen
bestätigte corona infektion eines der am
stärksten betroffenen länder ist indien
die zahl der korona fälle steigt dort
seit anfang mai immer mehr an
bei fast 500 29.000 menschen konnte das
virus nachgewiesen werden
es gibt mehr als 16.000 tote und ein
abflachen der infektions kurve ist nicht
in sicht
normen odenthal berichtet jeder tag
bringt neue rekorde mehr infizierte mehr
tote
corona hat indien fest im griff und
immer fester die großen metropolen sind
besonders betroffen allen voran delhi
die hauptstadt beschwichtigen beruhigen
das funktioniert nicht mehr
wir waren davon ausgegangen dass die
fälle zunehmen
aber mit so einem anstieg haben wir
nicht gerechnet wir kommen mit dem
testen nicht hinterher
jetzt werden die krankenhausbetten knapp
und weil wir zu wenig betten haben
erhöht sich die todesrate
eisenbahnwaggons stehen seit tagen
bereit als isolierstationen das war der
plan
doch der wackelt wieder weil es heiß ist
und stickig klimaanlagen sollen
installiert werden auch das einplanen
doch es wird immer klarer dass ganze
system ist dem kollaps nahe regierung
lobt immer wieder die leistung des
medizinischen personals und lässt es
dabei gleichzeitig in stich es fehlt an
schutzkleidung
viele ärzte und schwestern haben seit
monaten kein gehalt bekommen wir lassen
sie hängen
das virus verlangt indien alles ab das
land hat 1,4 milliarden einwohner und
ein marodes gesundheitssystem wahrlich
nahrhafter boden für die korona krise es
wird noch dauern bis die welt einen
impfstoff gegen korona hat damit aber
dann möglichst viele menschen geimpft
werden können wurde gestern fleißig geld
gesammelt
der internationale spendenmarathon wurde
auch von prominenten musik stars
unterstützt mit einem konzert das live
im netz zu sehen war
miley cyrus sang den beatles-hit help in
einem leeren stadion
euro
die botschaft der künstler wie shearer
gemeinsam gegen korona
[Musik]
tolle sache norbert und einem spannenden
letzten spieltag auch in der zweiten
bundesliga und zwar oben wie unten in
der tabelle heidenheim hat als
tabellendritter die relegation erreicht
und spielt gegen bremen um den
erstmaligen aufstieg in liga eins ja und
der hsv nur auf platz vier nach einer
desaströsen 1 5 niederlage gegen
sandhausen enttäuschung in hamburg bei
den gegentoren und frustration nach
schlusspfiff wieder nichts mit der
rückkehr des hsv in die bundesliga was
lief falsch die mannschaft wollte wollte
einfach nicht konnte nicht es bringt
einfach nichts
der erste liga da werden wir
kanonenfutter mit der heimniederlage
gegen sandhausen ist der traum vom
sprung auf den relegationsplatz für das
team von dieter hecking am letzten
spieltag endgültig geplatzt verspielt
haben sie den aufstieg in der gesamten
rückrunde sprichwort sagt ja der fisch
fängt im kopf an zu stinken
und das ist nun mal der hsv ganz oben
bleibt die hoffnung dass aus den
unabsteigbaren der vergangenheit nicht
die unaufsteigbaren der zukunft werden
direkt aufgestiegen sind bielefeld und
stuttgart und der blick nach unten wehen
wiesbaden und dresden steigen ab
nürnberg muss als tabellen sechzehnter
in die relegation
berlin ist zum neunten mal deutscher
basketball meister alba gewann auch das
final-rückspiel gegen ludwigsburg siegte
mit 75 zu 74 und kehrt nach zwölf jahren
zurück auf den basketball thron
zehn spiele zehn siege hochverdienter
meistertitel für die hauptstädter
nachdem die berliner bereits das
hinspiel mit 23 punkten differenz
gewonnen hatten
lassen sie heute keine spannung
aufkommen zu groß der vorsprung
insgesamt so dass die frage nach dem
meister schnell geklärt ist dieses viel
beachtete final turnier ein erfolg für
die basketball-bundesliga 35 spiele
unter den strengen hygiene regeln
absolviert und mit alba berlin sichert
sich die deutlich beste mannschaft auch
zu recht den titel und das war's auch
schon von mir denken was zum schluss
noch das wetter im norden viel sonne und
trocken im süden am vormittag schauer
und gewitter teils mit starkregen die am
nachmittag dann
nachlassen 19 bis 25 grad das war es von
uns danke für ihr interesse
christian sievers unterhält sich im
heute journal um drei viertel 10 mit
fernsehköchin sarah wiener über den
fleischkonsum in diesem land morgen
macht hier barbara hahlweg weiter und
ich empfehle jetzt berlin direkt unter
das energy